[Applaudissements]
oh ben ça c'est évident ce qui suit
c'est le même maxime guény effectivement
cette espèce de lapin dans les phares
lajoinie mois l'actuel c'était comme ici
qu'ils essaient de dire un mot il a fait
le plus râler pour faire un deuxième
bébé temps va laisser marine a joué là
pour voir votre avis marina de qui
s'agitent en baisse à ses principes
je ne sais pas ces festivals alors que
tu serais jamais quand j'avais dit
benjamin castaldi toujours connu
caroline ithurbide elle vient de donner
toute la crédibilité ou documentaires
sont benjamin as tu es sage 90e pas
julien autant c'est bien au nom et
regarder ghana tu m'as jumelles à côté
sa petite main alors la coupe et une
soeur jumelle barbarie du pcot voyages
low profile à elle été bien servis
annoncé ma baleine à gagner qui aiment
le football a reconnu magath file vers
ces nouveaux délais oui mais ça me rend
ses fringues
excuse moi ma grand-mère m'habiller
super bien ouais c'est le revenu
shopping après l été rapidement éliminé
un autre bébé qui est on au regard des
comme ça
cette année là jamais non non pas du
tout il était payant sur le de vannes en
me regarde j'ai donc cj grenier c'est
géraldine
non on avait là la jeune femme qui avait
une étoile c'est le fait vous avez une
peau me regarder et il savait déjà les
parents qu'elle passerait la télé qu'il
fallait cacher on a un autre ou pas
abbas a fait c'est benjamin c'est mignon
est allé ronchon reconnaît beau père
[Applaudissements]
ag.b j'avais déjà l'air heureux dans la
vie est entré surtout penser à dire à
votre père de deux mètres la chemise
dans l'héritage freudien parce que ça
c'est bête de près c'est un coach qui
comme les capucines monde à la faute ou
pas vous avez envoyé des photos floues
bon et maintenant alors peut-être que je
me dois vous savez avec le csa je
préfère être très prudent les enfants
peuvent aller se coucher vous pouvez
zapper maintenant car voici la photo de
gilles verdez petit
[Applaudissements]
m